foreign
state of Texas in Dallas and talk to the
great Kate what's up Kate
hey there how we doing
uh good good most part oh no what
happened what's up
I'm just
going to email I sent in that way I can
like articulate correctly okay
um my question so it's not very long but
it says I'm a Christian I've been a
Christian my whole life and there are
other Christians saying that the eclipse
that's happening next year has potential
to bring Doom and Gloom some articles
have said that it will be earthquakes
famine War they also say we should be
preparing for the worst we should be
storing up food and water and supplies
and I have been in just a constant state
of fear since reading it I'm struck
between feeling like I need to start
growing my own food which is an
incredibly overwhelming thought or that
this is just silly and I just need to
trust that God will take care of me and
my family and it has gotten to the point
that I don't even think I want to have
kids anymore
and we've been trying to conceive for 18
months and I've been praying and reading
and I just feel really scared and really
unsure
of what to do
so when you were reading this thing
about the eclipse happening next year
and the potential to bring Doom and
Gloom to the world
I want you to know I raised my arms and
smiled really big
and then as I heard you keep talking I
feel bad so you're gonna watch this and
I'm kind of was kind of a jerk I was
kind of making fun like anybody who's
telling you that is full of more
nonsense than
I can muster on on this day today
um I don't believe that there is any
possible
thing anybody could point to in the
present in scripture in the past
whatever
that an eclipse is going to bring Doom
and Gloom okay
so I want you to hear that
or here's a better way I can say it me
and my family and I'm kind of a prepper
me and my family will not be preparing
anything special for the eclipse okay
okay that's my promise number two
my wife and I waited a long long time we
waited till we got through grad school
we waited for a long time to have kids
and we have two beautiful kids
and if I could take my head right now
and stick it in my 25 year old body
I probably would have four or five
knowing what I know right now and I've
spent my career seeing the worst of the
worst and the grossest of the gross okay
my question for you is
often when we get stuck in something
like this
it just runs on a loop in a loop and a
loop and a loop like a roller coaster
that never ends
often when I've been working with people
over the years what I found is there's
other things in their life that are out
of whack
it could be how much money you owe
and your body knows you're not safe
it could be you have an unsafe
husband
that you know you're supposed to be
married to because you have your
religious beliefs and all that but man
it's not a very good person it could be
boundary issues with your family or your
boss it could be
you have a calendar that's open it could
be any number of things
but if you step back away from this
one thing
what else is going on in your life
that is chaotic and anxious
that's stressed
well
um I just got
well geez Kate lead with that
oh my gosh I'm so sorry
and it was completely out of the blue
yeah um are you in pain or is it just
they no okay it's silent yeah and the
doctor she even told me she said I'm
absolutely floored
that this is one of the worst cases
she's ever seen good gracious
and I will probably have to have a full
hysterectomy by the time I'm 40. and I'm
I'm 30 now
so hold on hold on don't heartbreaking
yeah there's no so yeah you just gotta
sit in that
you've wanted to be a mom for a long
time haven't you
I've been scared to be a mother and then
I finally make up my mind and it's like
oh nope you gotta go through all this
why are you scared to be a mother
um I've had a very traumatic childhood
and so
I've just been scared that I won't be a
good mom
that I'll be like my mom
I think you're going to be an awesome
mom
because I think that crap that happened
with you as a kid
one of your life missions is that along
the the family tree that is Kate and her
family
that stops with you
Fair
completely yeah I'm proud of you
so do you see if you back out so one of
the things we do with looping Thoughts
with we really try to solve
for the eclipse
right
one of the things we do with looping
thoughts is it's the way we try to
address them and that's whether it's OCD
or whether it's anxiety or whether it's
clinical or not right these are some of
these behavioral patterns
is
we have like a house and there's a hose
in one of the windows and it's just
pumping in
poisonous gas
and as a culture we've been pumping
poisonous gas into our house for about
200 years now
and
we have spent bajillions of dollars
trying to help the people inside that
house
with breathing treatment with ways to
clean their furniture with ways to deal
with the tumors that grow inside their
bodies because they've been breathing
this hair
and nobody's just backed out of the
house and looked around the street or
the neighborhood and turned off the
poisonous gas
that's a long-winded analogy to say this
your body remembers
the pain a mom can inflict
and then you married a guy he's pretty
good
he's the most amazing man in the entire
world so you won the lottery
that's not true you earned the lottery
you worked hard for the tip for this guy
and then y'all started talking about
families and kids and your body sounded
the alarms because your body knows that
story
and it's just trying to protect you
good on it it's just doing his job
you're not crazy
and then finally you do the work that it
takes to wrap your head around I'm going
to be a mom I'm gonna do this sucker
differently and I know it's going to be
hard and I know it's gonna be painful I
don't have to deal with crap from my
past I don't have to deal with stuff
that comes up in the future but I'm all
in
and then you get this kind of
Health news
so what I'm trying to tell you is I want
you to see your house is full of
poisonous gas I want you to see you're
not screwed up and you're not broken
okay
here is I'm gonna give you a couple of
things that I did mine was the stock
market and housing in particular
after the housing collapse in 2008 2009
I
I went bananas
and I followed every Financial uh
conspiracy theory housing conspiracy
theory and I really I created this weird
map and all these Excel spreadsheets on
how housing was going to collapse
they're gonna have to nationalize
housing and the government was going to
own my mortgage it was a whole big mess
and Kate none of it was real
wasn't true
and at the time we owed a ton of money I
bought a house I couldn't afford I was
not in a safe job
my wife and I's marriage were falling
apart we had experienced infidelity I
mean not infidelity in uh an inability
to have kids for a long long time
and
um
my body was rattling and then I was
blaming the housing thing see what I'm
saying
do you believe me when I tell you that
me and my family are not going to be
prepping for
the eclipse
I do from what I've heard you talk about
before for sure I believe you and make
no mistake I've got a prep plan for just
about everything but I don't have one
for the eclipse okay I will probably be
out on my front yard and here's the
beautiful thing
if I'm wrong I'll be dead
I'll be dead all right what am I gonna
what am I gonna do about it if Doom and
Gloom comes after listen if there's a
cosmic event after an eclipse
there's not a lot John delone is going
to be able to do in a backyard garden
right
yeah and I have two massive Gardens in
my house it's just not about this one
okay so here's something that I did and
became almost a sacred thing for me
you can do it however you want this is
just how I did it I'm pretty low-fi
I carried a note card with me at all
times and on the front of that note card
I would I I was it's really struggling
with ADHD and a bunch of stuff I would
write down my plan for the day and I
would check it off
but I also kept on that note card when I
heard something
I have a real bad have I can walk
through a room I get a restaurant and
I'll hear one guy be like well yeah I
hear that if something's about to
collapse and my body responds as though
that is fact and is happening in real
time
right that's what you experience too
right and now anytime you think about it
even your stomach starts to drop right
yeah yeah
I carried a note card with me and I
wrote down on that note card what was
just said
the US dollar is gonna go away
and I would look at that and say is this
true
probably not
maybe maybe but probably not
number two can I control anything about
this
yes or no
almost every time
the answer was no
and what it gave my body the ability to
do was to a acknowledge this outside of
me write it down
B go through the mental exercise what
can I actually do here
is a small suburban Garden going to
protect us if there's a cosmic event
after a eclipse no
no no
no just not
a bunch of coffee and cigarettes and
bullets aren't either
those are people that watch way way too
much TV and don't live in reality
okay over time after practicing this
my body stopped being so reactive to
things I couldn't control
it was just something I had to practice
but right now it feels good doesn't it
it feels like you're doing it feels like
you're practicing the future brene Brown
says it's like dress rehearsing tragedy
as though you're gonna think it through
and think it through and think it
through so when this thing hits you'll
be ready
can I promise you something
you will not be ready for whatever thing
may happen
in the future
it's not going to be
so we're going to take it as it comes
all right what's the prognosis on your
endometriosis are they going to do
surgery
um they can't do surgery it's too far
Advanced so they have put me into
medically induced menopause okay to try
and starve it out
for six months and after six months we
will try again naturally good wild
turkey if that works
that's a fun way to spend your 30th your
30s
how is your outlook on life have they
already started the hormone treatments
yes I'm
I'm started I did start going to
counseling just to help me monitor all
that because they did say two saddle
ideation was like a common
side effects so
I'm going every other week talking to a
counselor just to make sure that I'm not
spinning out of control when did your
workout when did you start getting
worked up over the eclipse
um a couple weeks ago okay
so I've seen a counselor since then and
we briefly talked about it but
um like this morning I woke up and I was
like look we're one day closer
and I like feel like I'm just trying to
con like you said is the control thing I
think
I spent so much time being the person
that was in troll control not actual
control but in control of how my parents
reacted to things you had to be that's
what I think I'm just responding
how I've grown up responding to things
yeah and you can't control this one and
you can't control the endometriosis and
you can't control
your husband's deep deep love for you
and his he's he's gonna be sad and you
are too
yeah part of grief
and
there's gonna be heartbreak and there's
gonna be frustration and
give me all that stuff
you can't control it it's like being on
the ocean man you can't control those
waves
the path through the eclipse as it is
I want you to use this word with your
counselor say I would like to enter into
some exposure therapy
okay and that is just oh that's
terrifying of course it is yeah of
course it is but it's the only path your
brain has pegged the eclipse
and anything about Eclipse anything
about starvation anything about Calamity
anything about
uh uh hurricane that happens this summer
or anything about anything about that is
going to set that off
the only way you heal your body from
getting set off from trying to protect
you it's just doing what it was designed
to do is to head directly through the
middle of that storm
that's it
and so if you get a phobia of snakes
what they would do is they would talk
about a snake for a meeting or two you
know talk about snakes which you hated
about them what they looked like what
you thought they might feel like then
the next meeting
they would have you you draw a picture
of a snake
in the next meeting they may have you uh
with a photograph of a snake
and you're talking about it what would
it feel like and by the time you get
done you're holding a snake and you're
laughing and smiling you can't believe
your body ever reacted like this that's
that's exposure therapy it's just
walking you through it
so they're probably going to have you do
some things like
um Google the number of apocalyptic
predictions
throughout time there's a lot that's a
fun Rabbit Hole to go down if you ever
don't have anything productive to do
with your life but you can go down that
rabbit hole and uh
they've all been wrong because we're all
still here
and one day there will be one there will
I'm confident
I'm also confident
at least the best I can
that it's not going to come on the back
of an eclipse
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you two things I'm going to send you my
book redefining anxiety I'm also going
to send you own your past change your
future for you and your husband okay I
want y'all both to read that book
um and you want you to read the anxiety
books it'll give you some short term and
long-term things it may be over time
after you get your hormones regulated
you're just I mean you're gonna it's
gonna be a while it's gonna be a messy
messy ride that's a tough tough road to
hoe
um
but it may be that I need some anxiety
meds for a short short season it may be
that I need to get another job start a
new exercise whatever that happens to be
but you're on a path
I'm really proud of you for calling
and I'm really proud of you for
considering going to your counselor and
say let's let's Stare this sucker down
let's Stare this monster right in the
face and walk right up to it you're
gonna find out that monster was just
smoke all along